maubert et guy pergaud descend d'une
lignée de paysans d'orchamps vennes
nommé maître d'école à belmont en 1877
la suite de l'histoire se poursuit au
pays de la guerre des boutons louis
pergaud comme son père deviendra
instituteurs les idées politiques de la
famille pergaud sont à l'avant garde
bien que je fasse ma classe
consciencieusement
j'ai déjà parce que je ne vais pas à la
mène une véritable croisade dénonciation
pétition délibération du conseil
municipal
j'ai tout le monde sur le dos rigon
cours en 1909 louis pergaud affiche son
antimilitarisme tout en étant patriotes
résolu à faire son devoir
le voile a officié dans les tranchées de
verdun une épreuve décrite dans ses
carnets de guerre le côté anti
militariste pur et dur qu'il était dans
sa jeunesse
on voit que l'aïe il est ça s'estompe à
peu sa solis et le côté anti clérical
une occasion il est allé à la messe dans
les tranchées il y avait un service
funèbre pour les morts du régiment et je
n'ai pas trouvé stupide d'honorer nos
morts même de cette façon nous
maudissons pas trop cette guerre qui
nous a permis de mesurer la profondeur
de notre amour et la puissance des liens
qui nous unissent
cette lettre est adressée à son épouse
delphine un amour fauché par la grande
guerre
delphine tous ceux qui me vient de toi
mais précieux je ne saurais jeter au
vent une enveloppe ou ta main s'est
posée
[Musique]
c'est la dernière photo de louis pergaud
elle a été prise le 6 avril 1915 moins
de deux jours avant sa disparition lors
d'une offensive
il faudra attendre plusieurs années pour
que le village de belmont inscrivent le
nom de pergaud sur ce monument aux morts
aujourd'hui un musée célèbre l'enfant du
pays